im februar geht das gartenjahr wieder so
richtig los und deswegen lass uns mal
darüber sprechen was jetzt im garten
fällig er ist
und da fangen wir an mit dem
komposthaufen der ist jetzt nämlich
ziemlich nass geregnet vor allem dann
wenn du vergessen hast denn über den
winter abzudecken und deswegen ist es
ganz klug den jetzt einmal umzusetzen
also das was innen ist nach außen zu
schichten und das was außen ist nach
innen zu schichten einfach der mieter
wieder ein bisschen mehr luft rein kommt
damit die mikroorganismen und die
kleinen boden tierchen wieder fleißig
anfangen können zu arbeiten sobald es
dann im frühling wieder ein bisschen
wärmer wird und dann kommt auch wieder
eine abdeckung drauf das ist ganz gut
damit die nährstoffe nicht ausgewaschen
werden gerade im winter früh legen wenn
es so viel drauf regnet dann ist es ganz
klar einfach eine plane darüber zu legen
und den komposthaufen davor ein bisschen
zu schützen ein problem im frühjahr ist
es dass der boden sich auch nicht so
schnell erwerben im 4 vor stehen ja
schon wieder die ersten ausfahrten an
auch draußen im weg und darüber sprechen
wir gleich noch aber vorher wollen wir
natürlich den boden vorbereiten einmal
damit die pflanzen ihre wurzeln gut
ausstrecken können und einen schönen
lockeren boden vorfinden aber auch bei
der boden im februar oft noch ziemlich
kalt bist und es dem hilft wenn man ein
bisschen belüftet das wärmere luft auch
nach unten in den boden eindringen kann
und wer meinen kanal schon länger
verfolgt der weiß ja dass wir ohne
umzugraben gärtnern weil wir so kaum
unkraut haben weil der boden wasser viel
besser speichern kann mir das sehr viel
freundlicher ist für die bodenlebewesen
dazu verlinke ich euch gerne mal im
video unten in der video beschreibung
wenn euch das interessiert und was jetzt
ganz klug es ist wenn man den boden
lockern ohne ihn zu wenden also die
natürliche schichtung bleibt erhalten
aber wir stecken in den boden ein mit
einer doppel grabegabel so nennt sich
die die kann ich mich auch gerne unten
in der video beschreibung verlinken und
bewegen die vor und zurück um den boden
ein bisschen zu lockern und dafür zu
sorgen dass die luft rein kommt und das
vor allem auch die wärme tiefer in den
boden eindringen kann dann gibt es noch
zwei sachen die wichtig sind bevor wir
dann nach draußen gehen können und
aussehen können und dabei geht es um das
saatgut da ist es jetzt einmal wichtig
dass noch einmal durchzugehen und zu
gucken ob man wirklich alle samen hat
die man braucht dann sonst noch mal
nachbestellen
oder eben auch auf saatgut im tausch
veranstaltungen zu gehen oder bei dem
saatgut tausch paket mitzumachen da gibt
es in verschiedenen internetforen oder
zum beispiel auch auf facebook tolle
gucken wo man sich zum saatgut reden
kann oder auch im paket herumschicken
kann wohl jeder seit gut rein gibt und
saatgut rausnimmt und so kann man viele
unterschiedliche bunte sorten
untereinander tauschen das ist total
schön und außerdem ist jetzt auch ein
toller zeitpunkt um das saatgut zu
organisieren ich bin da jetzt richtig
vorne mit dabei mit meinen neuen foto
boxen habe ich mein saatgut jetzt rein
organisiert und das ist ziemlich cool
und ziemlich praktisch hat sehr viel
spaß gemacht und ich finde ich die auf
dem balkon gärtnern können jetzt mal
alle töpfe aus lernen in eine große
maurer wanne oder irgendeinen großen
kübel da die ganze erde miteinander
vermischen ein bisschen dünner dazu
geben aber nicht zu viel soll ja auch
für die schwarzfahrer die man dann
später in den töpfen anbauen möchte
nicht zu viel sein und ein bisschen
frische erde dazu geben und so schafft
man es dass man auf dem balkon die
fruchtfolge umgeht das ist ja wenn man
im normalen garten gärten hat super
wichtig dass man jedes jahr eine andere
pflanzen familie auf ein und demselben
beete anbaut weil wenn man immer wieder
die gleichen gemüse anbauen würde dann
könnten sich schädlinge und krankheiten
total einfach da festsetzen deswegen
rotiert man die pflanzen immer durch
dass es auf dem balkon aber nochmal viel
schwieriger als in den normalen garten
und deswegen ist ein richtig cooler
trick einfach alle erde zusammen zu
werfen noch mal richtig auf zu pumpen
und dann wieder auf die köpfe zu
verteilen der februar ist außerdem der
beste monat um euch für meinen
gemüsegarten staaten online kurs
anzumelden
der öffnet heute also an dem tag wo
dieses video erscheint wieder seine
türen nachdem wir fast alle ausverkauft
war es ein video kurs den du ganz
gemütlich von zu hause aus in seinem
eigenen tempo durch arbeiten kannst das
heißt es gibt kein zeitpunkt zu dem die
unbedingt anfangen muss und es gibt auch
keinen zeitpunkt zu dem die fertig
werden muss weil du unbegrenzt lange
zugriff auf die kursinhalte hast so dass
du auch in drei jahren oder in fünf
jahren noch mal zurück gehen kannst du
dein wissen aufzufrischen
und ja ich bin einfach so wahnsinnig
stolz darauf was die leute hast den kurs
machen das ist einfach so unglaublich zu
sehen wie sich so ein garten in einem
jahr verwandeln kann und deswegen zeige
ich euch hier mal ein paar
videoschnipsel von dem gartenfreund
männerchors teilnehmerin katharina da
wird ihr mein gemüse bild was ich mit
hilfe bzw unter anleitung des kurses
gemüsegarten staaten angelegt habe
dieses jahr so und da sind wir ein
kleines gartenreich ich zeige euch mal
ein bisschen was da so wächst zunächst
mal wächst hier blumenkohl wir lieben
blumenkohl und er wächst auch richtig
toll dass der hammer wie schnell
gewachsen ist wir lieben ja auch
kohlrabi da wächst hier auch ganz viel
und weißkohl das wird alles immer größer
ist es also wirklich unglaublich wie
viel platz braucht hätte ich nicht
gedacht diese kleinen pflänzchen am
anfang hier wächst der wirsing nebenan
kommen die ersten gurken in die pötte
hier gibt's auch ein dill wald
und die hochbeete habe ich jetzt das
dritte jahr und ich habe dieses jahr
glaube ich schon mehr geerntet wie in
den letzten beiden jahren zusammen weil
ich eher ein bild gemacht habe und
gestaffelte aussaat mache und dadurch
das optimal nutzen so dass wir viel viel
mehr ernten und die auch eigentlich fast
nie leer stehen dann gibt es ja auch
noch zwiebeln und möhren europa wie groß
sie schon sind die kann man schon bricht
aber die sind richtig lecker auch schön
süß essen wir sehr gerne und auch
zwiebeln die wollte eigentlich gar nicht
antworten habe ich nur gemacht gegen
mischkultur hier ist das richtig dicke
dinger sind das geworden also mein beet
ich liebe dieses bild total ich hätte
nie gedacht dass man das in so kurzer
zeit so gut umsetzen kann und vor allen
dingen dass das so wenig arbeit macht
also wir haben fast keine arbeit mit
gießen und jeden wie versprochen im kurs
also es ist so ein neuer lieblingsort
den bei uns hier geschaffen haben vielen
vielen dank für den tollen kurs für die
tollen unterlagen für die hilfe auch für
die community das macht richtig richtig
spaß danke wurzelwerk wenn ihr lust habt
mit dabei zu sein dann packe ich euch
einen link unten in die video
beschreibung und auch hier oben hin so
dass ihr euch anmelden ich würde mich
wahnsinnig freuen wenn wir uns gleich im
kurs wieder sehen das war echt der
hammer dann ist jetzt auch eine tolle
zeit um den gemüsegarten aufzuhübschen
und da hatte ich so viele coole ideen
für meinen garten dieses jahr gesammelt
und auch letztes jahr schon ziemlich
coole ideen umgesetzt und wenn ihr
wissen wollt welche das sind dann packe
ich euch ein video in die video
beschreibung könnt ihr euch inspirieren
lassen und dann raus gehen und eure
garten projekte umsetzen was bei mir
jetzt auch ansteht ist dass ich meine
wege erneuern möchte ich lege die wege
immer mit hackschnitzeln an und die
hackschnitzel die ich hier verwendet
haben wir sind einfach schon drei jahre
alt und deswegen schon ziemlich
vergangen und deswegen werde ich meine
wege jetzt nochmal mit frischen
hackschnitzeln auffrischen wenn ich
nicht genug eigene hackschnitzel habe
dann bekomme ich die vom bauaufträge
betrieben aber jetzt steht ja auch der
obstbaumschnitt an und die
beerensträucher weil geschnitten werden
und das ist auch eine tolle gelegenheit
um selber hackschnitzel zu machen das
ist also auch noch eine aufgabe die man
nicht vergessen sollte hatte ich aber
auch schon im januar video deswegen eher
wenig sie immer nur kurz am rande und
was auch eine coole idee ist ich
letztens von freunden gehört habe ist
dass man jetzt einfach schon die ersten
reise aufhebt wenn man die obstbäume
schneidet weil man ja für die erbsen oft
gebrauchte mit brand gesetzt haben und
das ist ganz praktisch wenn man beim
obstbaumschnitt schon daran denkt bei
mir steht jetzt auch an das gewächshaus
sauber zu machen weil sich das schon
algen festgesetzt haben und es ist ja
gerade für die tomaten die dann ja
irgendwann da einziehen sollen auch sehr
wichtig dass möglichst viel licht durch
kommt und deswegen denkt daran dass ihr
euer gewächshaus vielleicht noch ein
bisschen auf frisch bevor die tomaten
dann reinkommen und natürlich stehen im
februar auch ganz ganz viele aussagen an
sowohl im haus bei der jungpflanzen
anzucht als auch draußen im beet und
welche pflanzen man da jetzt vorziehen
sollte und nach draußen aussehen sollte
darüber habe ich letztes jahr schon mal
ein komplettes video gemacht wenn ihr
wissen wollt welche das sind dann schaut
auf jeden fall da drüben vorbei
ansonsten geht raus und macht die welt
ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag um 10 für ein neues
video